but we're going to begin this hour with
former First Lady Michelle Obama who is
here in our studio live and in color she
is listen to this guys the number one
best-selling author of becoming in her
more recent book it's called the light
we carry overcoming in uncertain Times
by the way that was number one too to
travel the country she talked to Big
names about her recent book including
there was Tyler Perry Ellen Degeneres
and Oprah there's only one you can hear
those conversations on Michelle Obama
the light podcast the former first lady
also recorded a Netflix special with
Oprah during her final stop here is a
little sneak peek
so we're coming to stay with you
graciously hosting us and you said bring
your friends and I was like okay
um and she's like how many people I said
well it's like 12 12. and you're like
what'd you say you were like you don't
have 12 good friends I do
that was who I do I'm not done
good friends
who and and Oprah was like I got Gail
the only person I know it's 12 good
friends was Jesus and the disciples
[Applause]
one of them
but then you met my kitchen table yes
and you saw that I collect and keep my
friends throughout life
Michelle Obama we welcome you to the
studio I mean Oprah and I actually did
have a conversation about this because
we always say we don't have a lot of
friends I know a lot of people but when
it comes to friends and then we met your
friends and they really are your true
blue friends you know over the span of a
lifetime and it's just interesting
because you and Oprah have been kind of
in the same business yes right yes yes
but I have been a loyal
uh Law School student and I almost take
I've I have a friend from each era of
your life you know it's like you I tell
people you don't need a ton of friends I
agree with that even experience with one
good friend you're ahead of the game but
your friends have gotten you through
many things oh that's your gosh I know
you can trust them and it when when
you're at the level that you are it's
very very difficult I want to talk about
the difference between the two books
because becoming was a best-selling
novel over 12 million sold dropped the
microphone very much so when you started
writing the second one did you feel
pressure that I have to top that or I
want to make another bestseller no
actually there was no commitment uh in
my contract I didn't have to write the
book the book just sort of came you know
over the course of the last few few hard
years of being in quarantine dealing
with covet all the political uncertainty
you know I had a lot of time on my hands
to just sort of stew and to mull over
question questions that young people in
particular would ask about just managing
life in uncertain times and you know I
told you I took up knitting yes and a
lot of the ideas came as I was learning
to knit and thinking about how did I get
here what are the knitting after
learning it on YouTube you said I taught
myself that surprised me too yeah yeah
this is the thing about you you have
always been very candid very authentic
very much uniquely yourself and so many
people Mrs Obama at your stature when
people say how are you doing oh fine
fine but you have been very open about
your insecurities your anxieties even
even your frustrations why did you
choose to be so vulnerable and do you
regret being so vulnerable no no I don't
in fact you know it's the only way I
know how to be me yes and when you have
to operate at a high level I think it's
easier just to be completely yourself
then you don't have to keep up with the
lie or the facade that you've you've
kept up but I also think as a
responsibility it's a responsibility to
people with a platform you know in
particular young people are watching us
and a lot of times they uh glamorize the
lives of the famous and they don't
understand that we feel anxiety and and
guilt and remorse and fear so when they
experience those same natural emotions
they feel like something is wrong
because we don't tend to share the hard
stuff I don't think it helps anyone to
put on a brave face and to pretend to be
something that you're not
um and I I never want to be that I've
never been that person so what have you
learned about working through your own
anxieties that you think could help
others it is a practice first of all
I've learned to embrace the fact that
basic anxieties I'm not deal talking
about dealing with severe mental health
issues but basic anxiety is a part of
life you know anxiety uh has gotten me
where I am today you know uh not wanting
to mess up at school being anxious about
doing what I'm supposed to do you know
making sure I'm not living on the street
so I want to be able to have a job that
kind of anxiety you know it propels me
forward
um but I've also learned that sometimes
I gotta just step out of the noise
um and and know that I have to turn off
the things that cause me upset so there
are times even in the white house where
I just had to not hear anything you know
I didn't want to hear about the country
through the voice of someone else I I A
lot of times I let my experiences with
the American people shape my attitude
and nine times out of ten when I based
my feelings on my interactions with
people yeah I was was always in a better
place yeah because I say it's harder to
hate up close yes people are a lot
better one-on-one than we look when we
when we see ourselves on the news or you
know I know I know I've heard you say
that you know when you're in the white
house did you feel tremendous pressure
because all eyes were on you and I heard
you say once we just knew we could not
screw up I mean you had eight years
where there were really relatively no
scandals to speak of compared to the
compared to what we're dealing with even
now exactly I mean did you feel that
type of pressure when you were there
absolutely I talk about the pressures of
being the first being and only
um there's that other being the other
knowing that your successes and failures
Define the rest of your community and
others like you coming behind you so yes
Barack knew that he couldn't afford a
scandal I mean he wore a tan suit and
got criticized you know and you know you
wore long shorts and 110 degree whether
at the Grand Canyon people say look at
her and I knew I we debated we had a
long debate in the plane I said well if
I get off in a dress I'll look out of
touch because we're going on a hike yes
but then if I walk off in shorts some
fashion critic is going to say that's a
No-No so there's yes we were we were
always mindful of the example that we
set but guess what what that's what
you're supposed to be when you're
president of the United States and first
lady you should be mindful of the
messages the things that you say the
example that you set you know that's
part of the job yeah you know you're
also very candid about relationships and
I think you speak for many women when
you so candidly said I mean people took
off on this you know there were years
where you just didn't like a mini
spouses in this room will say you know
there's sometimes I don't like him I
don't like her yes so what was the
controversy it's like but you said it
out loud like we like everybody every
day it is impossible were there times
that you think he didn't like you
because I know you said I didn't
continue
what did he say I was wondering what did
he say he said you know I didn't like
him for 10 years I was mad at that
picture right no no the I I share these
things because marriage is hard yeah and
a lot of young people quit on marriage
um over things that are just a part of
the the commitment yes
um we've been married for 30 years I
know you know if I fell out with him for
10 and we had great 20 years I take
those odds any time but I don't we
glamorize marriage and then this day and
age marriage is more about the dress and
the dresses yes and the proposal and the
honeymoon and all the stuff around it
and young people aren't ready for the
real of marriage so I think once again
it's incumbent upon us people who have
had successful marriages to be really
honest about the fact that making a
commitment to be with someone means you
compromise and compromise ain't always
fun yeah and don't add kids into the mix
because they really mess up your life
well let's talk about kids because
people think God I hope she writes a
book on parenting honestly because you
have raised to very confident not
arrogant girls
thanks thanks not going with me I do
that all the time who are very poised
who are really generous human beings
yeah what did you want when they could
have been come out of the White House
and been very obnoxious and they were
not that has to do with the way they are
raised what is it that you want your
girls to know how you wanted them to
move in the world a lot of people could
take lessons from this gratitude because
they are way more blessed than we ever
were they had way more and learning to
parent with more was the thing I didn't
know
um I want them to have compassion and
empathy I want them to be independent I
want them to be able to stand on their
own two feet not depend on us and the
very important thing I want them to know
that their happiness is up to them yeah
that the world doesn't owe them anything
and neither does anybody else and
control happens when you know how to
make yourself happy where you know how
to create your own Joy yes um so those
are some of the things and what comes
with that are boundaries expectations
um uh giving them responsibilities
handing them their lives early you know
not not being afraid of allowing them to
fail standing back and letting them sit
in their failure and also it's okay for
them to make mistakes we we have bills
to pay around here Mrs Obama so we're
gonna have to take a break please don't
run out like your hair is on fire okay
we're going to continue the conversation
but first time to check your local
weather it's 8 12. we'll be right back
we're going to continue our conversation
with the former first lady her name of
course is Michelle Obama I have to say
something about the book because it's
called the light we carry overcoming in
uncertain times I really think that
these are uncertain times and I look at
the things in the news recently the
three recent shootings the terrible
shooting in Kansas City with the 16 year
old thank God he survived yes a young
woman in New York was shot turning in
the driveway just normal things do you
think that we can ever figure out a way
to reconcile gun violence in this
country because it does keep me up I
hope and pray that that at some point
enough becomes enough
um what's that point you know we
wondered that throughout our entire
presidency thinking that this time yeah
Barack Obama said the Newtown was one of
the worst days of his presidency and we
still didn't get that message but we are
the only developed country on the planet
where its citizens can have unfettered
access to Firearms
um that is not a good thing and more of
us have to feel strongly about it and
particularly our young people
um this is where democracy comes in uh
voting this all this stuff is decided in
the in The Ballot Box
um and then then you've got the Supreme
Court when they overturn Roe v Wade you
you put a very poignant message about
you were heartbroken what's your
reaction today as you see this a battle
over abortion access can continue to
play out
uncertain times scary times this is this
was to be predicted
um I I can't tell you how many times we
talked about the importance of the
Supreme Court the importance of voting
voting in every election uh so now we
are here I am not surprised by it it was
coming yeah now the problem is that our
young people have to understand that
just because an issue doesn't affect you
today doesn't mean it doesn't it's not
going to matter in five or ten years
voting matters that's all I can say I
know when you've said it over and over I
emceed this event at Lincoln Center jazz
at Lincoln Center for Wynton Marcellus
and just mentioning your name that you
were going to be on people
people have such expectations in hope
that will she will she I'm not even
going to ask you that but do you ever
wonder or do you ever think when will
politic politics leave you because you
said I'm not a political person politics
isn't what isn't something I wanted that
people still hope and want you to do
something
uh yeah
um it I am authentic if I were going to
engage in politics I would let people
know yeah but I am a public figure I
still care about these issues I will
always find ways to use my platform to
to speak out that's why I'm focusing on
getting young people to vote yeah
because none of it matters it doesn't
matter who's in the Oval Office if we
can't give them a Congress that they can
work with so we're not you know managing
our state houses and on and on I could
go on and on about it I know and I'm not
even pushing for you running that ship
is sealed I get it so what gives you Joy
these days Michelle Obama what are you
looking forward to yeah so much
um less than 30 seconds what is it other
than being with all of us today watching
my my girls become the women that they
were meant to be
um and watching young people evolve I
mean that's still the thing that gives
me not just Joy but hope is when I meet
these young people who are really
grappling with these issues in a major
way way they want to have an impact they
are so full of Promise that's why I stay
connected to young people because it's
the best way to remember the best of our
country we are so glad you were here
that you came to us in the studio you
should see Klaus doing the happy desk on
Steadicam there's Klaus Michelle Obama
you can listen to Michelle Obama the
light podcast now on Audible wherever
you get your podcast we'll be right back